the 2020 race is now well underway and
the Democrat candidates have endorsed
the most radical proposals in American
presidential campaign history we will
examine the substance of this primary
campaign then bado gets even creepier
who knew that could happen
Chelsea Clinton gets blamed for
terrorist attacks and young people are
really unhappy I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
all right so much to get to today it
occurred to me when I was looking at the
broader picture on politics that now
that the campaign field has kind of
really begun to flesh itself out Biden
hasn't announced yeah there a few others
who are going to get in but you're
starting to see them take policy
positions we now have beyond the
instagrams beyond the cooking and the
beer and the dental cleanings and beyond
all this sort of shallow superficial
stuff as just a matter of substance we
have the most radical presidential
policy field in all of American history
really really radical stuff so we're
gonna go through those proposals because
I think that the Democrats are trying to
distract you with all these videos and
dental cleanings and whatever but when
you get down to it they are advocating
some pretty radical stuff before we get
to all of that I've just got to check
what time it is so we've just started
the show you know I knew that because of
my movement watch baby my revolver
collection Atlas watch which I get more
compliments on than any other watch I've
ever had
movement is founded on the belief that
style shouldn't break the bank they've
sold almost 2 million watches worldwide
by bringing quality designs at fair
prices pick a style or design that you
personally like any of them they these
are minimalist these are sporty these
are they have a little something for
everybody and they're really sleek so
you could do I mean this is my I'm a
little more old-school as you might have
understood so I really like this kind of
retro futuristic collection it's got the
minimalist kind of forward-looking face
design but then it's got this kind of
cool old-school round pie pan it's
really good this is my favorite one the
one that I really want by the way my
birthday was just two days ago if you
want to send me one is the arc
collection the art collection is the new
automatic movement watch so it's not
quartz it's a little more mechanical
really really cool stuff movement
watches are all about looking good and
keeping it simple this was crowdfunded
this was started by college dropouts
they've sold one and a half million
watches in over 160 countries they start
at just 95 bucks in a department store
you'd be paying 3 400 bucks at least for
the
automatic watch probably significantly
more get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
MVM t.com slash cough fa co v fe fe
movements launching new styles on their
site all the time check out the latest
at MVM t.com slash cough fa co v fe fe
join the movement by the way I do have
to put in a plug before we get to the
Democrats radical proposals you know
been released his book yesterday the
right side of history so this thing shot
way up the charts I think it made it up
to number three bestseller or book on
all of Amazon now this is great but it
needs to go just a little bit higher it
needs so as you know look I'm talking to
you as a number one best-selling author
myself I what I really need to have
happen because I love the book I think
it's a really important book I think a
lot of people need to buy it you need to
buy just a few more copies to push that
book up to number two because it will be
very very satisfying and hilarious if
Ben's tome his magnum opus his
intellectual history of all of the West
makes it up to number two just right
below that number one bestseller reasons
to vote for Democrats a comprehensive
guide get the book today bump it up just
a little higher guys it was at three we
can go to to head over to Amazon Barnes
& Noble right side of history book
dot-com get your copy there's gonna be a
live book signing today only on today's
episode of the conversation at 7 p.m.
Eastern get a signed copy have a chance
to have your questions answered go to
premier collectibles calm / Ben Shapiro
do it you'll be glad you did more
importantly I'll be glad you did because
I'll say look Ben you sold all of these
copies and you came so close two reasons
to vote for Democrats but at at least
then a lot of people will read it as
they should it is a really really good
book what do we have in the 2020
presidential primary for the Democrat
Party I've identified at least half a
dozen real I guess closer to a dozen
wild left-wing proposals something we
wouldn't have even considered five years
ago ten years ago number
medicare-for-all what is
medicare-for-all when I heard that
slogans start to percolate on the really
left-wing websites a few years ago I
thought what a terrible campaign slogan
meant it makes us all sound like we're
really old people medicare-for-all
nobody wants that that's so this is
gaining steam it's now been endorsed by
Kirsten Gillibrand Cory Booker Elizabeth
Warren Kamala Harris number of other
people who are looking at getting into
the race what is Medicare for all it's a
socialist takeover of health care it
would make the American healthcare
system the leader in the world the best
in the world the freest if that leads
the world because we have free
enterprise an ability to create
prescription drugs to innovate to create
new medical technology it would take
that and it would make it more
government controlled than the health
care system in the United Kingdom more
government controlled than health care
systems in Western Europe and in
Scandinavia it would force 150 million
Americans off of their health insurance
this is not some fringe idea this is no
longer just being talked about on
Jacobin magazine or on these far-left
websites this is now being endorsed by a
ton of mainstream presidential
candidates many of whom in the case of
Gillibrand Booker Warren and Harris are
in the US Senate right now that's the
first one if the Democrats had any issue
that they were running on in 2018 in the
midterm elections
anything beyond orange man bad I hate
Donald Trump he's a baddy the issue that
they were running on his health care
that left his wonted government-run
health care in this country for over 100
years it looks like they're now at the
point where they're coming totally
honest with their proposals and they
want a full government takeover what
would that mean for you by the way
practically so 150 million Americans
lose their current health insurance that
means you don't get to keep your doctor
and it means that because health care is
a commodity because it's just labor and
property because it's a not a negative
right but a positive right what that
means is you have less choice health
care is going to be rationed it has to
be rationed in the sense that it's a
it's a limited good there's not an
infinite amount of healthcare in the
world so how is it rationed right now
it's rationed in a pretty good way and
there are a lot of ways to fix the
American healthcare system but right now
you have people have the ability to buy
healthcare that they want they can pick
the health insurance plan that they want
we just enrolled here here at the Daily
wire and you can pick the bronze or the
silver or the gold you can do HSA which
is a great program the health savings
account where you can put money in
before taxes to make your own healthcare
decisions there a lot of great little
reforms and options here to pick what is
best for you that is one way that your
own choice in the market and and the
amount of money that you want to spend
on health care versus the amount of
money you want to spend on rent versus
the amount money you want to spend on
Christmas presents for your kids that is
one way to allocate care to a lot of
people now in this system as the left
wants to present it they say that for
the poor you're just denied health care
you're dying in the streets that is
simply not true we have an
extraordinarily generous safety net for
health care in this country we have
Medicaid if you're too poor to have
health care we have Medicare if you have
statistically high medical costs because
you're a senior citizen we have a huge
safety net than all of the individual
states have their own programs then we
also have private charity and then if
that weren't enough you can walk into an
emergency room and you will be treated
not just if you're poor or not not just
if you're an American citizen even if
you're an illegal alien you'll be
treated we have a complex healthcare
system now some of those complexities
are pretty bad so for instance some of
the regulations that came up as early as
the 1930s some of the incentives to tie
it to employment have created some
problems as some of the regulations that
have just been put into effect because
of cronyism the inability to sell health
insurance across state lines is one
example some of those regulations are
burdensome they make the health care
system too complicated some of the way
we think about health care and health
insurance makes it burdensome and too
complicated for instance when you go to
the doctor and you have your annual
checkup
that is paid for by insurance but that's
not what insurance is insurance is when
you're you pay
certain amount of money because of a
risk that you will need money in the
future and so you're paying your monthly
premiums in case something comes up that
you can't expect and then the insurance
company which was willing to take the
other side of that bat was willing to
take on that risk will then pay you your
money the money that you need for your
health insurance that's what insurances
but if your know that you're going to
get an annual checkup that's not
insurance you're just I don't know
prepaying you're entering into a kind of
weird contract where you're paying a
monthly amount for something you're
certainly going to get every year all of
that is complicated however the
alternative is worse don't forget we've
been talking about this a lot as Russell
Kirk wrote in the conservative mind all
simple forms of government are bad he's
quoting other conservative thinkers all
simple forms of government are bad so ok
we have this temptation I think because
about complicated health care is in the
u.s. to say scrap it get rid of the
insurance companies Medicare for all
socialist health care make it simple I
don't need to worry about paying a
premium free health care health care has
never been more expensive than when it's
free so you scrap all of that what are
you throwing away you're throwing away
your choice you're throwing away a
complex and very moral system of
incentives for how to allocate care some
of that is by free choice some of that
is by resources some of that is by the
government to make sure that people
don't get left behind when you get rid
of all of that what do you have you have
the death panels I mean that what what
is meant by the phrase death panel is
that government bureaucrats choose to
allocate health care to whomever they
want that's what it is it's that rather
than this complex system that we
currently have with a lot of free choice
a lot of incentives for innovation but
rather than all of that it's a
government bureaucrat who decides who
gets care and who doesn't it's what you
saw with those babies dying in the
United Kingdom little Charlie guard baby
Alfie parents don't ever say the patient
doesn't have a say the government will
tell you if you're going to get cared
that's what is
being proposed not by some fringe of the
Democrat Party but by major mainstream
candidates that's just one policy I mean
I wanted to take a little time on that
because that is a major policy proposal
so many others that really in the grand
scheme of things are even more radical
we'll get to in a second but first let's
make a little money honey with micro you
have got to check out the way I heard it
with micro a terrific podcast especially
if you're short on time because each
podcast gives a unique take on American
history and each episode is just 10
minutes or less micro is the way I heard
it is for quote the curious mind with a
short attention span every episode is a
short mystery about a famous person or
event that you know filled with
surprising facts that you don't know
from pop-culture to politics from actors
to athletes from history to Hollywood
it's America's number one short form
podcast it's been downloaded more than
87 million times and the way to get
started if you haven't listened yet is
episode 100 how not to ruin your most
expensive suit what could that be about
I don't want to ruin it for you
it's about feeling pressure on the
world's largest stage it's a funny
episode all these episodes are pretty
funny they're true they are just a great
way to have a little insight into
America's biggest moments in history and
Mike is a terrific storyteller he also
reminds me a lot of Ronald Reagan if you
have ever heard clips of the Reagan
five-minute radio show from the 70s he
has this real Reagan s quality he's
witty he's got a lot of historical
insight it's it really holds your
attention it's just terrific microcon
slash podcast
check it out listen and subscribe to the
way I heard it mi ke ro w e comm slash
podcast that is micro comm slash podcast
okay that's just medicare for all next
policy they are proposing a national
minimum wage hike to $15 per hour who
came up with this Bernie Sanders who is
backing it now Kamala Harris Elizabeth
Warren now says that the minimum wage
needs to be raised because it's not high
enough to support a family now of course
the minimum wage was never intended to
support a family the minimum wage
was intended for teenagers the minimum
wage was intended for people who are
just getting into the workforce the
minimum wage is intended for a small
portion of the workforce and then
they're gonna move up and make more
money but the left is doubling down on
this because what is the logical
conclusion if Liz Warren is right and
the minimum wage is all we should aspire
to the minimum wage should be enough to
raise a family on on just one person
making the minimum wage obviously that's
not enough so what does that imply that
implies their next radical policy
proposal which is the universal basic
income universal basic income has gotten
some currency on the left and the right
it is an insidious idea it's a terrible
idea but it's the logical conclusion of
this Liz Warren minimum wage stuff which
is if you have to be able to raise a
family on the minimum wage you can't if
it's incumbent on the government to
provide you with everything that you
need to raise a family then the
government just needs to cut you a check
Weist why stop at just tinkering the
economy and making employers pay up to
$15 an hour
why not just cut a check we have a huge
welfare state as it is and this is what
the left is doing this this one has not
been talked about very much but Kamala
Harris proposed needle lift Act and what
the lift act would do is for families in
the middle class that's always
politicians talking about the middle
class they would get $500 per month now
this this would come to you as a sort of
tax credit but you could get it on a
monthly basis so $500 per month and what
do we mean by middle class do we mean
people making less than 40 grand a year
people making less than 50 grand a year
note you would get $500 a month for
people making less than a hundred
thousand dollars per year which is
pretty good money so now this is
starting to look a lot more like a
universal basic income she's not the
only one
Andrew Yang who is the Internet's
favorite Democrat candidate for
president he's this kind of weird guy
whose whole campaign is about just
giving people money from the government
just pure checks I mean this is this is
what the founders so feared about
democracy they said oh gosh
once democracy becomes widespread enough
the people are gonna realize that they
can bribe themselves with their own
money the people are going to realize
they can just plunder the rich the
politicians gonna realize they can just
dole out money to everybody and then
they're gonna win elections and Andrew
yang is the embodiment of this idea
Andrew yang the center of his campaign
has just given people $1,000 a month you
just get a check for $1,000 a month and
that's it and this even is not a totally
new idea McGovern when he was running as
a Democrat candidate for president
proposed $1,000 per year for Americans
in a universal basic income
obviously inflation has taken off a lot
since the 60s and 70s but this is not a
terribly creative idea it's the most
basic pandering idea in all of democracy
which is buy off voters I mean in this
case literally give them money but that
is the logical conclusion of these ideas
you remember the life of Julia was a
campaign experiment from Barack Obama
who showed through the life of this
fictitious woman Julia how from cradle
to grave Barack Obama's government was
with her the only step of the way and
actually the only meaningful
relationship she had as an totally
atomized individual with no other
relationships was to the government they
give her money for this they give her
money for that that give her a job they
give her this that give her that they
give her free college that's the next
radical proposal the Democrats have
picked up on free college taking away
tuition for college Joe Biden Bernie
Sanders Kirsten Gillibrand Kamala Harris
Liz Warren Tulsi Gabbard everybody wants
to take away the cost of college this
this might be the most insidious idea of
the whole proposal we just saw last week
in two weeks ago the college admissions
scandal we saw that people were
basically bribing college officials to
get their kids into colleges and the
real scandal of that was not that the
kids got in but it was that they were
able to graduate if these kids were so
stupid so uneducated so unintelligent
how were they able to graduate how we're
able to make it through in some cases
with pretty good GPAs it's because
College has been hollowed
from within why is college hollowed out
from within it's because the government
subsidizes every loan why is college
gotten so expensive it's cuz the
government subsidizes every loan why his
College gotten so politically correct
it's because the government when you're
on the hook to them is able to foist a
lot of regulations on them you see huge
administrative bloat
you see costs going up you see the
quality of the education going down and
as the left has been marching through
the universities now for well over 50
years all of these candidates realize
that the key to their progressive
political utopia is totally taking over
the colleges this is their chance the
way they're gonna do it is with
government controlled college liz warren
has already sponsored the college for
all act actually the only Democrat
candidate to push back on this is Amy
Klobuchar and I gotta tell you there's
something about Amy Klobuchar I really
like her she's I mean obviously she's a
left winger she's a typical but there's
something about her just curling her
desk lamp at her staffers there's
something about her eating salad on
airplanes with a with a comb and then
flinging at a staffer saying clean this
something I don't know gets my heart
going pitter-patter and she is
relatively a moderate in this field
she's the one to push back and say you
know maybe this isn't a good idea the
left does this all the time the left
creates a problem and then the left
insists that they are the only ones who
can fix the problem they did this to K
through 12 education totally destroyed
the education system in the United
States they say the answer now is more
leftist policy and people buy it we'll
see if they buy it in 2020 the other
side of free college is student loan
forgiveness in what other financial
bubble would you see an entire political
party the oldest continuous political
party in the United States coming around
and saying oh let's just forgive all the
loans how many trillions of dollars in I
think we're at a 1 1 and a half trillion
dollars in student loans in this country
and right now Liz Warren is calling for
it she called actually as early as 2014
for students to be
ex-students to be able to refinance all
of that debt Gillibrand also called to
be able to refinance all of that debt
and then the more radical proposals are
saying just forgive it all completely
and mark my words by the end of this
campaign you're gonna see a number of
candidates calling to eliminate and just
forgive the student loans altogether but
what is that going to do you might feel
good for the students who have a
$200,000 fake degree a completely
worthless piece of paper you might feel
good for them but what kind of incentive
does that create first of all their
creditors are gonna get totally screwed
over they're not going to be able to get
their money back but even beyond that
when the colleges and when the banks
realize that the loans are just going to
be forgiven or they're gonna be paid off
by the federal government I guess that's
the case in which the creditors don't
don't get totally run roughshod over
well then what happens then the colleges
say okay great
great let's just keep raising those
costs of tuition let's keep those
student loans coming because the
government's just gonna forgive it again
this is the problem with amnesty this is
why MST is such a big deal if we could
turn off the spigot of illegal
immigration today I think most people in
this country would be willing to grant
amnesty to just about everybody not the
criminals not the violent criminals but
just about everyone else I think people
basically would back amnesty so it's
easy enough we don't want to deport
everybody it's gonna take too long
however the trouble with amnesty is once
you give amnesty then it creates an
incentive for more illegal immigration
once you give student-loan amnesty once
you give loan forgiveness it exacerbates
the problem in the college's rather than
fix it that's what you're gonna see then
speaking of colleges you have Elizabeth
Warren calling for the abolition of the
electoral college it's not just her beta
work just today came out and said yeah
there's a lot of wisdom to abolishing
the electoral college the electoral
college one of our oldest institutions
for one of our most important decisions
which is electing the president and you
now have the mainstream candidates of
the Democrat Party calling for its
abolition why what is the purpose of the
electoral college as a few
one it's to restrain a pure democracy
very good very important that's a
wonderful thing
what is another purpose of the electoral
college doesn't just restrain democracy
let's say all of the American people
voted for super duper mecha Hitler or
somebody or they elected you know Stalin
jr. to be President the Electoral
College could come out and say nope
sorry we are going to disagree with the
American people we're going to elect
Baron Trump or somebody they're gonna
elect a good candidate so there's that
aspect the other way that they do it is
by removing the vote for president one
or two degrees from the people which is
very important because the people don't
elect the president the people
participate in votes in their states to
choose electors to elect the president
but the people don't elect the president
we are not a democracy we are a
democratic republic we have a
representational system of government
this is very important it's important
for the preservation of Liberty because
once you have more and more and more and
more direct democracy
you see Liberty disappear the tyranny of
a mob is just as bad it's actually worse
than the tyranny of a dictator or of a
bad monarch or somebody like that now
calling to abolish that now they're
going to abolish the electors they're
going to abolish the electoral college
but don't worry because a major Democrat
if not the leading Democrat in the
country Nancy Pelosi is calling to allow
16 year-olds to vote so we want to
destroy the electoral college but then
we want to expand the electorate to
include 16 year-olds why in her word so
that she can capture them when they're
kids when they're impressionable when
they're immature when they're juvenile
when they're uneducated when they are
being indoctrinated by leftists in the
school system well they've still got
them the presidential candidates haven't
come out for this yet mark my words at
least one of them will come out for this
before the end of the primary they're
advocating packing the Supreme Court
they want to add a ton more justices to
the Supreme Court Liz Warren Kamala
Harris Kirsten Gillibrand Cory Booker
they want free universal preschool you
see the
from Julian Castro and Liz Warren so
they don't you don't want you know I
want you to have your kids for very long
you've got it you have the kid the kid
comes out then immediately goes into the
government run by leftists for a
universal preschool then K through 12
then we want free college so everyone's
got to go to that college system pretty
soon we're going to have free post
graduate education free grad school or
professional school so the government
has your kid the whole time
indoctrination the whole time then they
want to redefine capitalism Elizabeth
Warren has the accountable capitalism
Act
this would make corporations
unaccountable to shareholders this would
make them accountable to politicians
this would give workers a 40 percent
membership on corporate boards and this
would censor corporate political speech
that's what they want and we're not even
close to the most radical plans they
have yet we'll get to reparations for
slavery in a minute we'll get to why
bado of work is so creepy but first
you've got to go to Daley wire.com
ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get to test questions and the
mailbag you get the Matt Walsh show you
get to ask questions backstage by the
way get your mailbag questions in for
tomorrow I'm gonna be in Missouri
tomorrow I'll be giving a speech at
Truman University I'm gonna be bringing
this with me because otherwise I could
drown I'll be flying all across this
country I'll be taking the same air
routes as all those candidates up maybe
I'll see betta on the airplane who knows
you're gonna need these left two steers
tumblers where you're not gonna survive
past 2020 go to Daley wire comm we'll be
right back
so you've now got the Democrats
proposing to take your kids from two
years old all the way to after college
you're now redefining capitalism you're
redefining corporations you're up ending
the economy you're in giving everybody a
universal wage you're raising the
minimum wage you're giving everybody
socialist health care the government is
now taking over just about every sector
of the economy and then once all of that
is done the 2020 candidates are calling
for reparations for slavery that I don't
know I mean this is woke because slavery
ended in 1865 so it's only you know 150
years ago at this point the woke earth I
want to know when are we gonna give
Turks reparations for the Crusades well
actually when are they going to give us
reparations for the Battle of Tours when
are we going to give people reparations
for the Spanish Inquisition when there's
been a lot of conflict throughout
history when are people going to have
all of their reparations this obviously
is an impractical and impracticable plan
Julian Castro Kamala Harris and Liz
Warren all behind him Cory Booker is
actually one of the people who says this
is not really practical and he hasn't
come out for it but he does want a
policy to close the racial wealth gap
and his policy is baby bonds so the baby
bonds low-income people people who don't
have a lot of wealth would get
government bonds when they're born and
the bonds would mature and so it would
help them build wealth I'm not totally
opposed to this idea in theory I'm just
opposed to the injustice of it and and
the perverse incentives that would
create how come only some people get the
baby bonds but not others where's that
where do you draw the line for the baby
bonds I mean this is just the
redistribution of wealth and if certain
people know that they're going to get
baby bonds below a certain income level
aren't they going to just stop working
isn't that gonna harm productivity isn't
that going to have the same sort of
negative incentives that so many other
welfare programs have Bernie Sanders
also is not calling directly for
reparations
slavery because Bernie Sanders is an
old-school socialist he's not the new
intersectional socialist so for the new
intersectional socialists everything
it's about class and race and religion
and sexuality it's all the struggles
combined man into this quasi-mystical
quasi religious system bernie is much
more old-school than that for him it's
just class conflict so for Bernie what
he's saying is look we're just going to
give a lot of money to poor people but
that will help black people because
blacks are disproportionately poor which
I'm sure at some point someone's gonna
say this is offensive for him to
campaign like this but nevertheless
that's his version of it all the same
we're talking about a redistribution of
wealth specifically to address racial
problems after that we have a job
guarantee program this is not pie in the
sky cory booker's already sponsored
legislation for it that legislation was
sponsored co-sponsored by Liz Warren
Harris Gillibrand and Sanders job
guarantee program in America they have a
job guarantee program in China too they
had a job guarantee program in the
Soviet Union as well and then of course
the ps/2 the resistance the green New
Deal the green New Deal the wackiest
proposal we've gone over it I don't need
to go over it again but in broad strokes
that outlaws planes trains and
automobiles and knocks down every single
building in the country then it rebuilds
it within ten years it knocks down
eighty eight percent at least of the
American energy industry it actually
could go as high as the mid-90s percent
of American energy just within the
energy industry this would destroy five
point eight million jobs on day one and
by day two all of those other jobs that
are downstream of the energy industry
would be destroyed as well which is to
say virtually all of them
how many people do you think support the
green New Deal you would say this is
just Alexandria okay Jie Cortez right
this is just couldn't possibly no way
Amy Klobuchar Bernie Sanders baito
O'Rourke here Kamala Harris Liz Warren
Cory Booker Kirsten Gillibrand and even
Pete Boudicca goo goo goo goo goo you
know the mayor of South Bend Indiana
he's running
a long shot campaign he's running for
president Pete but the good will go Gaga
goo boo goo ba ba ba Ferg I believe does
he once he pronounced he pronounces it
with a with the edge edge Pete Pete but
did juju Pete but did you judge it I
don't know it's one of those things
anyway he supports it too they all
support the green New Deal what does
this mean for the primary this means
this is a race to the left this means
they are all going to be running over
themselves so they even where certain
candidates haven't embraced the far-left
yet they will by the end of the primary
it's only March what does this mean for
the field broadly it means that actually
there might be some daylight for a
centrist candidate they're all running
over themselves because they think the
Democrat Party has been pushed so far
left radicalized by Trump that the only
candidate who can win is the furthest
left the most intersectionally approved
the trouble for this is if they're all
running left it doesn't matter if you're
the second most left-wing candidate
doesn't matter if you though I'm the
third most left-wing candidate no only
the furthest left works so what this
does is it actually creates a little
daylight for an alternative for a
centrist candidate that's where you see
Amy Klobuchar is making a couple moves
in that direction
Beto O'Rourke making a couple moves in
that direction some Democrats and media
figures are recognizing that same thing
actually morning Joe is now calling for
an explicitly old news old Democrat
party what would today be considered
centrist candidate and it's hilarious
except maybe there's something to it
really I see one person on that list
that I can tell you today would beat
Donald Trump who is it do you think see
two who do I think you think it again I
think it is uh Carla Harris John Kerry
yeah for all the reasons I told you I'd
be worried because of the sabermetrics
of Joe Biden he's done it in 88 he's
done it in 2008 he doesn't like raising
money you think about all of those
things now you go back to John Kerry's
one shot in 2004
sitting ik running against a sitting
president
right after 9/11 right after the
beginning of at that time a popular war
John Kerry raised tons of money he knows
how to do it Joe Biden does it John
Kerry likes raising money Joe Biden
doesn't like to do it John Kerry came
within 80,000 votes in Ohio of being the
next president the United States again a
couple of years after 9/11 in the middle
of a war
John Kerry if he ran would win that's
not gonna say it's all I'm gonna say
it's pretty interesting to say that he
would be the 46th president the United
States if he announced today he was
running a nobody could stop a very very
sophisticated observer of American
politics who you both know very well I
was out with him last week we were just
walking around and he was looking at the
field and he said to me he said you know
who has the best chance of doing this
and he's not in and I said no he's John
Kerry okay well you go okay I know what
you're thinking you're thinking these
people are so disconnected from reality
there is no way that the Democrat Party
would ever nominate Thurston Howell the
fourth John Kerry lovey Theresa Theresa
honey get the yacht I want to go out and
shun they're never gonna nominate that
guy in 2020 right maybe accept the
wisdom here is that as everybody else 21
candidates jumping over themselves to be
the most left-wing candidate whoever
ends up winning that race is going to be
so totally unacceptable that the
Democrats will realize that person can't
win they will go for a safer bet a guy
that who's been has been around for a
while who is a little bit more centrist
I think that there is some wisdom to
that it's just the odds of that
happening are so low really probably
what the reality is this the Democrats
have made their far radical leftist bed
and now they have to lie in it so what
does this mean for the general election
this is a huge benefit to Donald Trump
because Democrats have learned the wrong
lessons from Trump they look at Trump
who is it a sort of extreme figure and
they say we need to be extreme on policy
say no
this is not actually what Donald Trump
did they've convinced themselves that
Donald Trump who is extreme is extreme
on policy he's not he's a pretty
mainstream conservative on policy pretty
mainstream Republican some ways he's
even breaks with Republicans like that's
break the criminals at a jail bill that
he did right before Christmas I didn't
see a lot of conservatives thrilled
about that whole paid family leave is
not looking like a great conservative
policy necessarily but he's been good
he's kept his word more than other
conservatives have so you got a thank
him for that still that's not extreme
he's just extreme on the tweets
he's extreme in his blunt language he's
extremely honest actually about his
political plans but what did he call for
it called for building a wall securing
our border he actually wants to increase
legal immigration to the highest amount
ever it's a little strange but it's not
extreme in the conservative position
it's actually extreme in the liberal
position he wants to stop illegal
immigration he wants relative peace
abroad he wants to deregulate the
economy wants to cut taxes there's kind
of basic Republican and conservative
stuff so the Democrats took from that
that they have to be extreme ideologues
now the confounding factor here is they
have very high voter enthusiasm on the
Left right now we saw this in 2018
democrat enthusiasm was very high
Republican enthusiasm was very high so
what this means is you could see a blunt
force election you could see really high
turnout on both sides really ideological
turnout on both sides really extreme
ideological views and then there remains
one question mark 808 Oh is a major
question mark because who is bado who is
all we know about bado
comes to us by way of CNN this is seen
as a moment by some where Democrats want
to nominate either a woman on our
minority federal work is neither of
those things
O'Rourke is a white male something
that's very evident to everyone and that
is that he's a white man he's also a
white male and he's conscious
of his white male Nasim a not be open to
another white male another white male
another white male a lot of the energy
and the party right now is not for a
white man vulnerability is running as a
white man as a white male being a white
man something he can't change being a
white man who says I'm you know I was
born to do this
gosh you know to say that it just sort
of drips of of white male privilege Edo
or work benefited from white privilege
one of the big debates is whether 2020
is the year of the white man he can't
get over the fact that he's a white man
so he just has to accept that not the
right time for a a white man to run for
the presidency there's a white man the
right guy to you know to be the next
nominee there's still an issue in this
country where people just get very very
excited about white men
he seems very self-aware of his
perceived weaknesses in this case you
know the fact that he's a white male
that's all we really know basically is a
white guy that's all we know we don't
really know about his policies because
he kind of has a little bit of both and
even all of the profiles of bado they
basically just talk about superficial
things there was a piece in The
Washington Post so glowing on him I have
to read you this because it tells you a
lot about our culture it's called the
politics of bado and Amy O'Rourke's
marriage Beto's campaign for president
has put his marriage in the spotlight
showcasing a relationship that is at
once the most modern and most
traditional of any 2020 candidate listen
to just the first paragraph bado
O'Rourke plunked down on his living room
sofa beside his wife Amy and promptly
removed his shoes and socks it was a
late February morning weeks before
announcing his candidacy and bado had
just returned from his favorite hike in
the nearby mountains his head was still
in the clouds I'll do Beto's voice I've
read Amy this passage last night from
the best interview I've ever read he
said it's about myth and different
religions and it said much the way
you're unconscious and subconscious
sorry I'm saying both of these words
wrong he turned to Amy for help
your subconscious said Amy who like bado
is thin and angular but whose tawny hair
is not yet streaked with gray okay yeah
the same way your subconscious
the author of your dreams dado said
leaning forward to rub his bare feet
which elicited a slight groan from Amy
in the same way your will is the
subconscious author of your life that's
what we know about him I have to agree
with CNN he's just the most cliche
liberal white boy
thirty-five-year-old recent college
graduate
I've ever heard of he's such a Iza
skateboarding androgynous weirdo he is a
total empty vessel on the campaign trail
the other day he came out and he told
voters he said please shaped me into the
presidential candidate you want shape me
he says into the presidential candidate
that you want how about you have a form
you're supposed to the reason you can
shape him is because he doesn't have a
spine he's an invertebrate so you can
just shape him any way you want like a
big lump of clay
he's you're supposed to have a spine
this reminds me there were three kinds
of politicians there are conviction
politicians the ones who are true
believers who really on the left or the
right there are the power-hungry
politicians they don't really care so
much about etiology they just want power
and then there is a third type and the
third type of politician is bored rich
guys that is beta O'Rourke he's not a
conviction politician he holds both
sides of every issue in 2012 he said the
US needs significant spending cuts the
US has out-of-control spending now he's
advocating all of these giant ninety
three trillion dollar policies in just
the other day he called himself a
capitalist then he calls himself a
socialist he endorses the green New Deal
all of you doesn't know quite where he
is because he doesn't it doesn't matter
to him now it's not that he's even
power-hungry well the reason I read that
first bit from The Washington Post is he
just seems like a guy who's enamored of
his own voice who's enamored of his own
face he never quite got out of college
he never learned three much in college
he wants to just have freshman bullsááá
Asians and feign purpose feign insight
be a dime-store philosopher and he's a
bored rich guy the guy's worth 9 million
bucks his wife is a billionaire heiress
what what else is he gonna do he just
wants to run for president just be
shaped however you want to be shaped
this guy is the big question mark in the
race because he's the perfect politician
for Millennials so his candidacy doesn't
require a lot of thought he's a freshman
year
fake philosophy bull session politician
he makes sense to the senseless he's
perfectly glib and shallow
he's he seems tolerant and open-minded
say beta what do you think about a $15
minimum wage okay hey what do you think
about abolishing the electoral college
yeah there's a lot of wisdom to that hey
bado what do you think about the green
New Deal yeah I like it hey check out my
cool skateboard though hey yeah man
that's a cool skateboard he also might
bring Texas over 38 electoral votes
would obviously completely end the
campaign right there within the race
he's both the centrist and a radical is
everything to everybody he doesn't yuck
anybody's young and he's so Instagram
about and this last part is the key I
mean this is going to be a confounding
factor in 2022 because my prediction in
2020 is that the media will not matter
as much the media you know Donald Trump
broke the media in many ways but it
wasn't just Donald Trump he had a big
role in it but technology broke the
media the media broke themselves the
media lost so much credibility just look
here's Jim Acosta just the other day
whining and complaining about President
Trump getting softball questions and
then he was asked that question by a
reporter with the Daily Caller right at
the very end you know it was the
question was was asked in a way that
really teed it up like like a game of
t-ball here in the Rose Garden the
president was just sort of served up a
softball there when he was asked you
know whether or not the Democrats are
advancing a lot of socialist ideas okay
that was Beta Beta that was Jim Acosta
complaining
about president Trump's questions from
reporters now here is Jim Acosta asking
a question of President Obama when he
met with the Brazilian president I'm
sure Jim Acosta he doesn't like those
softball questions like Donald Trump was
getting here's a hard-hitting question
from Jim Acosta I wanted to ask you
about what some people are calling your
best week ever last week you had two
Supreme Court decisions supportive of
the Affordable Care Act in of gay rights
you also delivered a speech down and
Charleston that was free we warmly
received it seems that you've built up
some political capital for the remaining
months of your presidency I'm curious
how you want to use it what hard things
do you want to tackle at this point in
terms of my best week now my best week I
will tell you was marrying Michelle that
was a really good week really tough
stuff really tough questions back in
that stuff so guy I mean Jim Acosta is
the example the embodiment of the
mainstream media people don't pay
attention now it's about Instagram I
mean that is why the candidates are
speaking to you directly not just Trump
all the others all the 20/20 Democrats
and it's all smiley smiley Instagram you
know George Carlin said when fascism
comes to America it won't be with
jackboots and brown shirts it will be in
Nike shoes and a smiley face t-shirt
smiley smiley and what we're seeing now
with extreme radical proposals most
radical policy proposals in American
presidential history we're seeing them
come to us not through normal political
means not through the mainstream media
not through political institutions
they're coming to us directly with
smiley smiley candidates Instagram
[Music]
upload emojis happy happy joy joy that's
what we're getting that's a confounding
factor in the campaign and we're gonna
see those two poles of it playing
back-and-forth policy radicalism and
presentational shallowness and glibness
and hopefully our electorate isn't so
shallow and glib that we're going to
allow them to sneak all of those
terrible ideas through through appealing
to our egos and appealing to our a lack
of attention
appealing to our scrolling scrolling
smiley smiley I'll see you all in
Missouri we're gonna show tomorrow then
I'll be giving a speech tomorrow night
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show the Michael
Noel's show is produced by Robert
Sterling executive producer Jeremy Moore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Danny D'Amico audio is
mixed by Dillon case hair and makeup is
by Jessa
all Vera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19